you had a rough like we mentioned the
World Series of Poker uh losing 1.1
million dollars over 48 days what were
you going through mentally during that
so here's the thing you know I do like
you said I do a YouTube Vlog every day
so I kind of share my thoughts and
listen I can edit that thing and keep
out the bad stuff but I think it's more
authentic and genuine to show people the
actual struggles and the pain that I go
through you know without it and I'd say
the one thing I'm most proud of
throughout the entire thing is the
resilience because there are moments you
see me where I'm broken I'm just like I
can't take it I broke a selfie stick
this year like I was filming it because
you know I do for my Vlog I smash the
stick threw it in the corner right it's
just that was my like hit rock bottom
moment and then I put the camera on me
and I was like all right I let people
see it but mentally it was very
difficult because
there was a feeling of hopelessness
where
you can I was making good decisions like
I genuinely felt like I'm playing really
really well but every time my money went
in and my opponent's money went in and
say I was 60 70 80 for about a two week
stretch I lost every one of those and
you start to wonder you're like I can't
win if I never win you know in these
spots so it was difficult luckily I have
you know 20 odd years of experience on
how to deal with it and so as I said I
wake up the next day ready to go it's as
if nothing happened to a certain degree
obviously you know the more the more it
happens in the higher binds like the one
where I broke the selfie stick I lost
500 000 in that tournament right and it
was like the last card it was painful I
think you lost yeah let's create that
video
I think he lost I agree what led up to
the uh selfies the gate like what you
just lost your [ __ ] for a like 100
milliseconds
like it was very brief you're just like
what the world wasn't making any sense
like how am I do I keep losing kind of
thing how did you why did you lose your
[ __ ] you should never really think like
this but part of me felt like I deserved
to win this yes right so part of me was
like listen I've lost so many in the
last two weeks all right let you know
the poker Gods be kind to me right now
let me win this and it looked good yeah
I was in a great situation on the Flop
great situation on the turn I'm about to
be a competitor I'm going to be a
contender in this tournament to win a
big prize pool and turn the whole thing
around it's all there for the taking and
then boom the last card it just you know
it was a couple weeks of frustration in
the moment of filming that I just had
you know sort of a visceral reaction you
know and I smacked uh smack the selfie
stick and then like I it was I see a
corner it's safe I threw the selfie
stick on the ground and of course social
media blows up about how you know I was
a violent act yeah you know I mean it's
like if you've never watched Sports have
you never seen a guy on the golf course
smack his club or throw their helmet
like you know there was the there's a
guy Justin bonimo who's a poker player
yeah and he's a super I had for lack of
a better work offended by everything and
he was equating my throwing a stick on
the ground to violence against women
domestic abuse and the idea that like
this makes women feel unsafe to play
poker and so that was kind of a running
joke for the last two weeks where every
time I sat at a table the guys would be
like oh I feel unsafe
yeah can you take me through the hand do
you remember what the hand was like what
was the yeah so it was a you know a
player on the button raised David Peters
very aggressive player he he went all in
from the Blind and I had a pair of
pocket tens so I went with my tens and
he had Queen ten of Spades so I was good
I have way the best hand and the Flop
was like King nine three one Spade turn
was like the eight of spades so now he
has a flush draw and the river was
another Spade so he caught Spade spade
and he made he made a flush well but
statistically you were winning the whole
time yeah I was winning up until the
last card what did he go all in on was
it a bluff he made what's considered
like a pretty standard play in modern
poker where you know a guy raised and he
was just trying to pick up you know what
was there and he ran into a hand in the
big blind and you know he got lucky so
what was the throughout the strategy of
preparation and strategy of play so
you're playing so many days is are you
trying to ignore the results and stick
to a particular strategy yes for the
most part you know what I'm trying to do
is like if I formulate a strategy for
the whole seven weeks because there's a
very there's a varying degree of buy-ins
too like you have small ones like 1500
then you got like 250 000 buy-in so I
map out
the seven weeks and right I'll give a
little bit of mental energy to the 1500
which means I'll be on my phone I'm not
gonna I don't care as much about this
one but the 250k fully engaged fully
focused you know up against obviously
the higher the buy-in you know super top
competition and you know as far as
strategy goes focusing on each day
playing the best I can not the result
like because if you focus on the result
you're you're focused in the wrong place
your focus should be on the decisions
you actually make right and if you're
making good decisions consistently you
have to continue to do that the
frustrating part is this with poker
unlike chess or other things making the
best possible decision doesn't mean you
win often you lose you don't chest
well as a Magnus Carlson has also talked
about that
there's some
non-deterministic thing about Chess too
given a limited uh cognitive capacity of
the human mind so he he says that the
world championship should have 20 30 40
50 games not not the few that they have
it's too low of a sample so in that
sense the high stakes uh poker
tournaments are very too low sample sure
yeah well when you think of the World
Series of Poker so you like as you said
I lost about one million right in one
tournament that was 500 000. yeah so
then you know like a few others here of
high buying tournaments so the sample or
the amount was
you know 40 50 total tournaments with
you know High variants and if you don't
run well or do well in the highest
buy-ins you know you're going to have a
losing summer